[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à Bruxelles nous
sommes au cœur du Parlement européen
comme toujours cette semaine direction
les étoiles le 12 novembre 2014 un petit
robot filaé s'est posé sur une comète
nous avons rencontré les scientifiques
qui ont porté cette mission dans
l'espace la mission Rosetta n'est pas
finie mais y y a-t-il encore un budget
pour financer les grands programmes
spatiaux en Europe nous en discuterons
avec deux invités mais d'abord
l'actualité la Banque centrale
européenne est un acteur incontournable
dans la zone euro mais est-elle sortie
de son rôle c'est la question que nous
poserons à notre invité Robert Rochefort
député européen vice-président de la
Commission du marché intérieur d'abord
explication en
image
[Musique]
c'est la tour de contrôle de l'eurozone
installée à Francfort en Allemagne la
Banque centrale européenne a pour
mission de garantir la stabilité des
prix son statut lui interdit de prêter
directement aux États contrairement à la
Réserve fédérale américaine ou à la
Banque
d'Angleterre mais les temps Chang la
crise de la det qui frappe le continent
en 2008 conduit la BCE à intervenir de
plus en plus pour voler au secours des
états endettés sans violer les traités
elle utilise ce qu'elle appelle des
instruments non conventionnels une
palette de technique qui lui permet
notamment de racheter massivement de la
dette publique sur les marchés des bonds
du trésor grec espagnol portugais elle
prête aussi des centaines de milliards
d'euros aux banques de la zone l'annonce
d'un ralentissement de l'activité en
Europe fait monter la pression sur la
BCE le spectre de la déflation l'a
conduit à intervenir à nouveau sur la
politique monétaire elle lance un
programme de rachat illimité de dettte
italienne française ou allemande but de
l'opération faire baisser les taux
d'intérêt pour inciter les investisseurs
à prendre plus de risque alors la BCE
est-elle désormais au service de la
croissance
européenne avec nous Robert Rochefort
bonjour bonjour Merci d'être sur le
plateau d'urope hebbdo vous êtes député
membre du groupe ADLE le le modem en
France
enfin vous avez été élu sous les
couleurs de moden vous êtes membes de la
Commission du marché intérieur et des
consommateurs vous êtes économiste vous
allez nous expliquer un peu la portée de
de toutes ceses interventions de la
Banque centrale européenne est-ce que
cette BCE serait mise au service de la
croissance européenne est-ce qu'il y a
une évolution de son rôle ou il faut
d'abord dire merci à Monsieur dragi
monsieur Dragui est depuis quelques
temps le seul leader européen qui est à
la hauteur de la situation mais il faut
dire aussi qu'il est le seul à la tête
d'une institution fédérale donc il lui
permet de faire des choses donc Mario
Dragui président de la BCE donc Mario
Dragui président de la BCE ce qu'il fait
est très bien il va jusqu'au bout des
limites possibles que le traité lui
permet mais soyons clair une politique
monétaire est au service favorise une
politique de croissance mais ne peut pas
à elle toute seule relancer la
croissance économique c'est la
responsabilité des des états oui parce
que il y y a deux sujet pour que la
croissance reparte en Europe
premièrement il faut un plan
d'investissement massif alors c'est ce
qu'on appelle ici le plan
Junker sur des grands investissements
qui concernent l'Union européne est-ce
qu'il est si massif que ça d'ailleurs
parce que oui il est quand même il est
quand même significatif il pourrait être
plus élevé vous savez que les États
avaient la possibilité de l'abonder en
mettant de l'argent supplémentaire mais
aucun des états n'a voulu le faire ce
qui au passage me permet de vous dire
que le troisième facteur et qui par
contre re la manque c'est une politique
économique cohérente entre les
différents états tant que nos politiques
économiques ne sont pas harmonisé et
bien tout ça est un peu freiné donc la
BCE fait beaucoup mais c'est pas
suffisant mais en tout cas c'est c'est
trop déjà pour des un pays comme
l'Allemagne qui qui redoute que cela
donne un signal un mauvais signal pour
les pays voilà exemple que je vous
indiquis voilà l'exemple que je vous
indiquais il y a des divergences il y a
les faucons c'est l'Allemagne il y a les
pays du Sud qu'on se considère souvent
comme des pays laxistes mais en deux
mots qu'est-ce que fait la BCE la BCE
pour la période tout à fait récente
vient de lancer ce qu'on appelle le
programme de quantitative easing
c'est-à-dire de rachat de dett pour une
somme très très important mais de toutes
les dettes compris français et sauf grec
d'ailleurs la grec ne pourra pas la
racheter parce que la BCE ne peut pas
avoir à un moment donné plus d'un tiers
de la dette publique d'unun d'un état
dans ces livres or là la la Grèce est
déjà tellement aidée euh a été tellement
aidé que pour l'instant c'est pas vers
la Grèce que ça c'est important de faire
cette précision quandême bah oui alors
sauf que si la Grèce rembourse euh ses
échéances à court terme elle pourra de
nouveau prétendre puisque d'une certaine
façon elle aura remboursé la BCE elle
pourra réemprunter alors il y a quelque
chose qui peut paraître un peu étrange
mais mais c'est souvent comme ça que ça
marche juste un mot quand même euh la la
BCE en faisant ce rachat massif euh non
seulement euh AINS à ce que l'argent
reste pas cher donc normalement ça
permet à l'économie de repartir quand il
y a des projets mais encore faut-il
qu'il a des projets mais aussi est dans
son roule puisque vous savez
contrairement au reportage qui a été
indiqué l'objectif de la BCE c'est c'est
pas de ne pas avoir d'inflation du tout
c'est d'avoir une inflation de 2
% aujourd'hui ce qui nous menace c'est
la déflation en Europe la déflation
c'estàdire une inflation négative et ça
c'est le le pire des cauchemars alors
elle rachètera massivement ses dettes
publiques
mais avec l'espoir que les acteurs
économiques les banques les les
entreprises et les consommateurs
puissent emprunter ou investir mais
encore faut-il que les banques jouent le
jeu encore faut-il surtout queil y a la
dette publique à racheter c'est ça qui
est un peu le paradoxe c'est que les
banques puisque vous en parlez les
banques aujourd'hui ont de la dette
publique des différents États mais les
banques ont besoin de placer dans des
dans ce qu'on appelle des emprunts qui
sont sûrs or les dettes d'État
aujourd'hui sont sûres et les banques
finalement reçoivent aujourd'hui une
rémunération qui est quand même
significative pour ces ces dettes d'État
donc l'idée de de de la BCE c'est de
racheter cette dette des États mais
quand cette dette est déjà placée auprès
des banques il n'est pas sûr que les
banques effectivement donnent cette
dette en réalité ce que fait aussi la
BCE c'est très important c'est qu'elle
donne un signal psychologique et
politique de confiance elle dit elle dit
on est là et on soutiendra les choses
mais vous avez raison les banques ne
vont peut-être pas du coup récupérer de
arargent auprès de la BCE pour placer
dans l'économie mais ce n'est pas
vraiment complètement de la faute des
banques c'est de la faute de ces
politiques économiques qui ne sont pas
assez intégré et surtout de ce plan
d'investissement dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui est un plan dans lequel nous
avons beaucoup d'espoir mais
reconnaissons-le qui n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui très concret et très
opérationnel alors un petit mot très
vite de de commentaire sur ce nouveau
délai accordé à la France par Bruxell
qui lui donne donc 2 ans de plus pour
espérer rentrer dans les clous du pacte
de stabilité écoutez le commentaire de
Pierre Moscovici le le commissaire aux
Affaires
économiques les réformes entreprises
depuis 2 ans vont dans la bonne
direction mais dans le contexte actuel
elles n'ont pas encore suffit à corriger
cette situation sachant que l'objectif
de 3 % n'est pas atteignable en 2015 il
fallait prendre une nouvelle
recommandation ce sera fait dans les
jours qui viennent avec une trajectoire
de retour vers 3 % à l'horizon 2017 soit
un délai de 2 ans supplémentaires qui va
exiger des efforts importants de la part
de la France c'est très clair et la
commission sur ce point est tout à fait
exigeante alors 2 ans de plus à la
France ce qui nous amène à 2017 allée
électorale est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura des qu'il pourrait y avoir des
sanctions si elle ne respecte pas je
suis triste pour mon pays la France
parce que vous voyez bien que ce que
nous demande Bruxelles enur c'est pas
quelque chose qui est fait pour faire
plaisir à Bruxelles c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour notre pays plus
nous retardons et là c'est la troisème
fois qu'on retarde plus c'est nous-même
que nous pénalisons vous voyez bien
parce que là il va falloir faire quoi
cette année 4 milliards d'économie
budgétaire supplémentaire parce qu'on
les a pas fait dans les années
précédentes ça va contraindre la
croissance alors il y a la loi Macron
qui est actuellement toujours en examen
au Parlement européen que le
gouvernement a a du mal à à faire passer
d'ailleurs est-ce que ça ne suffit pas
pour Bruxelles vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un escar
vous savez l'escargot ce petit animal il
a une coquille comme ça c'est-à-dire si
on prend l'escargot par l'extérieur on a
l'impression qu'on tourne autour du pot
qu'on ne s'y rapproche que lentement en
tournant et cetera la loi Macron c'est
comme les réformes insuffisantes que
nous avons fait jusqu'à présent
c'estàdire on va vers l'objectif central
mais on y va extrêmement lentement on on
ne s'attaque pas à la chose la plus
important pour concl cette émission
quelle est pour vous la réforme
prioritaire à mener en France pour dans
essenti porte sur le marché du travail
assouplissement contrat contrat de
travail unique en contrepartie mettre
l'argent de la formation professionnelle
au service des chômeurs c'est ce qui
pourrait être quelque chose de gagnant
gagnant et une réforme et une
simplification considérable du droit du
travail et des seuils du code du travail
et et des seuils salari en particulier
de 50 qui soient remis en cause parce
que on sait très bien que c'est un
obstacle à la croissance de l'activité
économique en France et c'est ça dont on
a absolument besoin on a pas fini d'en
parler merci beaucoup Robert RF d'avoir
été avec nous alors loin du pacte de
stabilité je vous propose de rêver un
peu puisque l'Europe c'est aussi de
grands projet spatiaux le 12 novembre
2014 un petit robot s'est posé sur une
comète signant un exploit européen nous
avons rencontré les scientifiques qui
sont à l'origine de cette mission c'est
à damstad en Allemagne reportage signé
Germain andriilleux et Khalid
[Musique]
Mamoun
le 12 novembre 2014 à plus de 500
millions de kilomètr de la terre la
sonde européenne Rosetta lar F sur la
comète l'atterrisseur finit par se poser
entre de relief à l'ombre du soleil et
attend de recharger ses batteries mais
après 10 ans de voyage interplanétaire
l'émotion de l'Agence spatiale
européenne
[Applaudissements]
ESTM J pour l'Agence spatiale
européenne voici le centre des
opérations à darmstad en Allemagne où
toutes les missions en cours sont suivi
et
contrôlé pour Paolo fer l'histoire de
filae est loin d'être
terminée la mission n'est pas finie car
nous espérons d'ici quelques mois avoir
des températures plus élevées et plus de
soleil pour recharger les batteries et
dans ce cas si cela se produit nous
aurons l'opportunité de faire encore
plus d'expérience
avec F est qu'un des instruments de
Rosetta la sonde européenne vient de
réussir mi-février un survol de la
comète churi à seulement 6 km d'altitude
Rosetta continuera d'explorer de
photographier et de travailler en 2015
voire en 2016 proseta c'est essayer de
comprendre un peu de d'où vient le donc
l'origine de
l'univers